so there I was surrounded by my friends
and already for my happy ever after at
least that's how I pictured it the
reality was much more single
screw off still not to dwell on the
negatives in any positives to note
absolutely loving my new life have tough
job as a producer of news program I'm
looking for someone
dynamic to lead any volunteers do you
need the bathroom budget and maintaining
good relationship with X oh yeah very
well thanks how are you I'm fine
pacified global whiskey please double
and my love life is showing signs of
improvement mayor its aside from one
tiny development I'm pregnant
everything is completely under control
sort of
it's Evan look at you oh no Bridget
who's the father
this is Marx there's at least a 50%
chance Charles did you have a three-way
so this is doubt I presume so glad you
could be here this is a unique and
wonderful moment dr. Rawlings if you
could maybe give me a safer sir this is
dad I presume I'm so glad you could be
here this is unique and marvelous moment